s’expliquait par le coût élevé des journaux difficiles à obtenir.
Par conséquent,
les gens allaient au café pour y lire un exemplaire partagé.
Une fois au café,
ils rencontraient d’autres lecteurs du même journal,
ils discutaient, échangeaient des idées
et créaient un collectif.
De la même manière,
la télévision et le câble étaient très chers,
on ne regardait donc pas de match chez soi.
A la place, on allait au bar du coin
acclamer son équipe avec les autres supporters.
Mais, comme le prix des médias diminue au fil du temps grâce à la technologie,
ce besoin partagé qui nous rassemblait jadis disparaît.
Nous avons tellement de possibilités incroyables pour nous divertir,
et pour autant, il est plus facile que jamais de se retrouver seul à en profiter.
Notre société en porte les conséquences.
Par exemple,
le nombre de gens qui déclarent avoir au moins deux amis proches
est à son plus bas historique.
Je pense que la cause principale
en est la possibilité actuelle de se divertir sans les autres.
Une tendance va à l’encontre de cette atomisation de la société :
les jeux vidéo multi-joueurs récents.
Les jeux vidéo sont comme un feu de camp partagé.
Ils sont à la fois interactifs et communicants.
Ces feux de camp peuvent contenir de belles animations,
des quêtes héroïques,
parfois trop de coffres à butin,
mais les jeux vidéo d’aujourd’hui sont très différents
de l’activité solitaire d’il y a 20 ans.
Ils sont profondément complexes,
intellectuellement stimulants
et, par-dessus tout, sociaux par nature.
Un des récents succès du genre et un bon exemple de ce changement,
c'est la bataille royale.
100 joueurs se parachutent sur une île et le dernier en vie gagne la partie.
Voyez-le comme une sorte de « Nouvelle Star »
avec plus de bagarre et moins d’André Manoukian.
Connaissez-vous « Fortnite » ?
c’est un très bon exemple du genre de la bataille royale,
déjà joué par plus de 250 millions de personnes dans le monde.
Tout le monde depuis les enfants du quartier
jusqu’à Drake et Ellen DeGeneres.
2,3 milliards de personnes jouent aux jeux vidéo dans le monde.
Les premiers jeux comme Tetris et Mario étaient de simples énigmes et quêtes,
mais avec l’essor des jeux d'arcade, des jeux en ligne,
et des jeux massivement multi-joueurs avec aujourd'hui des communautés florissantes
les jeux vidéo sont devenus un loisir
qui demande un vrai contact humain.
Cela nous amène donc au streaming.
Pourquoi des gens se filment-ils en jouant à des jeux vidéo ?
Et pourquoi des centaines de millions de personnes dans le monde
se rassemblent pour les regarder ?
J’aimerais que vous imaginiez tous une seconde –
que vous atterrissez sur une planète étrangère,
où se trouve un grand rectangle vert.
Dans ce rectangle vert,
des extra-terrestres en tenue assortie
tentent de pousser une sphère à damiers entre deux poteaux
seulement avec leurs pieds.
La partie est plutôt serrée,
le ballon va et vient,
mais des centaines de millions de gens la regardent de chez eux,
acclamant, s’enthousiasmant et se connectant avec les joueurs.
J’ai grandi en regardant le sport avec mon père,
je comprends donc pourquoi le football est à la fois divertissant et captivant.
Si vous ne regardez pas le sport,
vous aimez peut-être « Danse avec les stars »
ou « Top Chef ».
Quoi qu’il en soit, le principe est le même.
Quand on aime beaucoup un loisir,
on a tendance à aimer regarder les autres le pratiquer
avec habileté et brio.
Ce serait déroutant pour un extra-terrestre,
mais créer un lien autour d’une passion commune est universel chez les humains.
Les joueurs ont donc grandi en attendant un divertissement interactif en direct,
et la pratique passive ne leur semble pas aussi épanouissante.
Les flux en direct sur Internet ont décollé grâce aux jeux vidéo.
Car ils offrent la même sorte de sentiment d’interactivité.
Quand vous imaginez ce qu’il se passe sur Twitch,
ne pensez pas à un million de diffusions en direct de parties de jeux vidéo,
mais plutôt à des millions de feux de camp.
Certains sont des feux de joie –
d'énormes feux de joie crépitants avec des centaines de milliers de gens autour.
D'autres sont des rassemblements plus petits et intimes
où tout le monde connaît votre nom.
Essayons tout de suite de rejoindre un de ces feux de camp.
Salut Cohh, comment ça va ?
Cohh : Salut, comment ça va Emmett ?
ES : Je suis à TED avec près d'un millier d'amis proches
et nous pensions venir vous rejoindre pour une petite diffusion en direct.
Cohh : Génial ! content d'avoir de vos nouvelles.
ES : Cohh, peux-tu partager avec le public de TED ici présent –
ce que tu as appris de ton collectif sur Twitch ?
Cohh : Alors, par où commencer ?
Je fais ça depuis cinq ans maintenant,
et si une chose ne cesse de m'impressionner au quotidien,
c'est à quel point Twitch est incroyable pour la communication.
Je joue à des jeux vidéo depuis 20 ans,
j'ai dirigé des guildes de jeux multi-joueurs depuis 10 ans,
c'est le genre de passion pour laquelle il y a peu d'endroits en dehors des jeux
où on peut rencontrer autant de gens partageant les mêmes intérêts.
J'écoutais un peu au début :
j'aime l'analogie du feu de camp, j'en utilise une semblable.
Je vois ça comme un groupe sur un grand canapé,
mais une seule personne a la manette.
C'est un peu du genre « Passe les chips », vous voyez ?
700 personnes comme ça –
mais c'est génial et vraiment c'est –
ES : Cohh, quelles sont les discussions en cours actuellement ?
Peux-tu nous en parler un peu plus ?
Ma vue n'est pas très bonne, mais je vois beaucoup d'émoticônes.
Cohh : Voici mon collectif, c'est la Cohhilition.
Je publie tous les jours.
Je viens juste de finir un défi de 2 000 jours
et, à ce titre, nous avons créé un collectif assez incroyable
sur ce canal.
Actuellement, nous sommes 6 200 personnes.
Vous voyez une avalanche d'émoticônes souriants « Salut TED »,
de cœurs,
de « C'est formidable »,
de « Salut tout le monde ».
Une masse immense de personnes –
énormément de joueurs
qui passent tout simplement un bon moment ensemble.
ES : Y a-t-il quelque chose que – peut-on faire un sondage ?
Je veux poser une question en ligne.
Y a-t-il une chose que l'espace de discussion voudrait que le monde,
en particulier les personnes avec moi en ce moment à TED,
sache ce que les joueurs retirent de leur pratique des jeux vidéo
et de leur appartenance à ce collectif ?
Cohh : Oh, waouh.
Je commence déjà à voir beaucoup de réponses.
« J'aime l'esprit positif. »
« Les meilleures communautés sont sur Twitch. »
(Rires)
« Ils nous aident à traverser les moments difficiles de la vie. »
C'est un message que je vois beaucoup sur Twitch,
c'est très bien.
« Un collectif très positif »,
« beaucoup d'esprit positif »,
c'est vraiment super.
ES : Cohh, avant que je ne retourne à ma conférence TED,
ce que je devrais probablement faire à un moment –
(Rires)
As-tu quelque chose d'autre à partager avec moi
ou une question à poser
que tu as toujours voulu exprimer devant un public ?
Cohh : Honnêtement, pas trop.
Je veux dire, j'adore ce que tu construis actuellement.
Le streaming interactif
est la grande frontière inexplorée de l'avenir du divertissement.
Merci pour tout ce que tu fais à la tête de Twitch.
Plus on entendra parler de ce que tu fais,
mieux c'est pour nous ici.
ES : Super, Cohh. Merci beaucoup.
Je vais retourner donner cette conférence,
mais reparlons-nous plus tard.
Cohh : Parfait !
(Applaudissements)
ES : C'est une nouvelle façon d'interagir.
Nous avons pu influer sur ce qui se passait sur le flux,
nous avons pu créer ce moment avec lui
et nous avons vraiment eu une expérience multi-joueurs avec le groupe et avec Cohh.
Chez Twitch, nous avons baptisé cela,
en toute logique, le « divertissement multi-joueur ».
Car regarder une vidéo seul ou regarder un flux interactif en direct
correspond à la différence entre jouer à un jeu solitaire
ou à jouer à un jeu multi-joueurs.
Les joueurs sont souvent à l'avant-garde des avancées technologiques.
Par exemple, les micro-ordinateurs ont été utilisés très tôt pour les jeux vidéo
et les tout premiers portables numériques grand public n'étaient pas des téléphones,
mais des consoles Game Boy...
pour jouer aux jeux vidéo.
Et, ainsi,
vous pouvez vous faire une idée de ce que l'avenir nous réserve.
Regardez ce bac à sable drôle et interactif que sont les jeux vidéo
et demandez-vous :
« Que font les joueurs aujourd'hui ? »
Vous pourriez avoir une idée de ce que l'avenir nous réserve
à tous.
L’une des choses que nous voyons déjà sur Twitch,
c'est que le divertissement multi-joueurs arrive dans le sport.
Twitch et la NFL se sont donc associés pour proposer du football en direct,
mais au lieu de présentateurs en costume qui diffusent le match,
nous avons invité les utilisateurs de Twitch à venir
le diffuser eux-mêmes sur leur propre canal
et à interagir avec leur collectif
pour en faire une véritable expérience multi-joueurs.
A mon avis, si vous pensez à l'avenir –
seules quelques centaines de personnes peuvent devenir présentateurs sportifs.
Un nombre infime de personnes auront cette chance.
Mais le sport est sur le point de devenir multi-joueurs,
c'est-à-dire que tous ceux qui le souhaitent dans le monde
auront la possibilité de devenir présentateurs sportifs
et de tenter leur chance.
Je pense qu'un nombre incroyable de nouveaux talents sera libéré
pour nous tous.
Et on ne demandera plus : « As-tu pu voir le match ? »
A la place, on demandera :
« Sur quel canal as-tu vu le match ? »
Nous le voyons déjà à l'œuvre pour la cuisine, pour le chant –
on voit même des gens qui se filment en train de souder.
Et tout se passera autour de ce feu de camp métaphorique.
Des millions de feux de camp seront allumés
au cours des prochaines années.
Sur chaque sujet,
vous pourrez trouver un feu de camp
pour créer des liens avec des gens qui ont les mêmes passions dans le monde entier.
Dans l'histoire de l'humanité,
les divertissements étaient par nature multi-joueurs.
Nous avons chanté tous réunis ensemble,
nous avons partagé les actualités tous réunis ensemble sur la place du village,
et, à un moment, en cours de route,
cette conversation à double sens est devenue une transmission à sens unique.
En tant que personne ayant le souci du collectif,
je suis impatient d'un monde
où nos modes de divertissement nous connecteraient au lieu de nous isoler.
Un monde où nous pouvons nous lier les uns aux autres autour de nos intérêts communs
et créer de vrais collectifs puissants.
Les jeux, les flux et les interactions qu’ils promeuvent
ne sont que le début d'une rotation
vers notre passé interactif, riche d'actions collectives et multi-joueurs.
Merci à tous d'avoir partagé ce moment ici avec moi.
Je vous souhaite de trouver votre feu de camp.
(Applaudissements)